la liverpool team ya ha conquistado un
país entero y lo ha hecho sin disparar
ni un solo tiro habéis oído bien
mientras todo el mundo habla de ucrania
y otro país que ha caído totalmente en
manos de rusia sin que casi nadie se
haya dado cuenta de qué país estamos
hablando
exacto bielorrusia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
para quien no lo conozca hablamos de la
última dictadura de europa y esto no lo
decimos nosotros lo reconoce el propio
presidente de bielorrusia alexandr
lukashenko atentos el gobierno
autoritario es algo propio de mí y
siempre lo he admitido alexandr
lukashenko es mejor ser dictador que ser
gay alexander lukashenko en otras
palabras bielorrusia es una dictadura
salvaje pero porque decimos que putin
les ha conquistado pues atentos
[Música]
el 27 de febrero de 2022 bielorrusia
probó un cambio sustancial en su
constitución lo hizo a través de un
referéndum con todas las garantías
democráticas que caben esperar de un
país como bielorrusia es decir ninguna
con estas nuevas enmiendas bielorrusia
permitirá rusia establecer bases
nucleares en su territorio territorio
donde ellos han establecido miles de
tropas rusas para desplegarse en ucrania
en el terreno político y económico
bielorrusia y ha firmado acuerdos con
rusia para tener políticas comunes en
materias como impuestos finanzas y
política industrial
[Aplausos]
el objetivo final es terminar formando
el llamado estado unido es decir que
bielorrusia termina formando una unión
política con rusia os lo hemos contado
en anteriores capítulos de visual
política el kremlin siempre has soñado
con anexionarse bielorrusia esto viene
de antes incluso que de que putin
llegara a presidente sin embargo el
dictador bielorruso lukas anka siempre
se ha mostrado muy reticente a esta
unión
ahora las cosas han cambiado podemos
decir que lukashenka le debe su
supervivencia política putin la guerra
de ucrania ha sido sólo el pretexto para
avanzar más rápido en la anexión sí es
cierto moscú se está desangrando
económica y militarmente la guerra de
ucrania ha sido una decisión calamitosa
en casi todos los frentes pero tenemos
que ser justos en lo que respecta a
bielorrusia putin se pueda notar un
éxito
[Música]
la pregunta ahora es qué pasaría si
lukashenka cayera mejor aún qué pasaría
si el apoyo de putin fuera lo que
hiciera caer a lukashenko atentos
entonces estás masivas contra la guerra
en bielorrusia 800 detenidos pero
esperado un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de protesta
los ciudadanos de bielorrusia están
haciendo todo lo posible por parar la
guerra de ucrania y si hablamos de mucho
más que protestas mirad esta noticia las
conexiones de ferrocarril entre
bielorrusia y ucrania se ha saboteado
para impedir el paso de las tropas rusas
hablamos de grupos organizados para
hacer la vida imposible a las tropas
rusas estacionadas en bielorrusia y no
son pocos en estos momentos podemos
decir que lukashenka tenía casi toda la
sociedad en contra la pregunta es y qué
pasa con su ejército pensando bien un
dictador como lukashenka necesita tener
a sus fuerzas armadas bajo control qué
pasaría si lo perdiera de verdad es
posible que bielorrusia caiga de las
manos de putin justo ahora que estaba a
punto de convertirse prácticamente en
una región de rusia hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
pero un momento antes de continuar
los precios de la electricidad el
petróleo y el gas están por las nubes
llamado récords de 14 años por culpa en
gran medida de la falta de inversión y
bajo semejante contexto la invasión rusa
de ucrania ha sido algo así como el
remate por eso ha comenzado a extenderse
una pregunta podría el hidrógeno llegar
a sustituir al gas ruso que empresas y
países están liderando esta nueva
revolución energética no te pierdas el
vídeo que han hecho en si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera de mutuactivos con el que
participamos os dejamos el enlace abajo
en la descripción y ahora sí vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
y silicon valley soviético
pues son un videojuego que se llama
world of tanks seguro que muchos lo
habréis jugado o incluso habréis oído
mencionarlo en algún canal de youtube
porque se trata de uno de los
videojuegos más populares de los últimos
años lo que seguramente no sepáis es que
este juego está hecho en bielorrusia
habéis oído bien y no no se trata de una
empresa estadounidense con oficinas en
meet la empresa que desarrolla world of
tanks fue fundada con capital bielorruso
y tenía sus oficinas centrales en la
capital del país todo esto es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que
bielorrusia es una dictadura con poco
más de 9 millones de habitantes sin
embargo hablamos de un país más rico de
lo que parece vamos a decirlo claro
lukashenka puede ser un dictador
abominable pero no es tonto desde que
llegó al poder en 1994 se aseguró de
lograr tres objetivos estabilidad
económica paz y soberanía y en cierto
modo lo ha logrado podríamos decir que
vino rusia pertenece al grupo de ex
repúblicas soviéticas que ni siquiera
intentaron hacer una transición al
capitalismo se puede ver incluso en sus
símbolos nacionales que todavía
mantienen estética soviética mirada
[Música]
de hecho el partido comunista sigue
formando parte del gobierno a diferencia
de rusia ucrania bielorrusia ni siquiera
se planteó un proceso de privatizaciones
a día de hoy más del 50 por ciento de su
pib está en manos de empresas estatales
el estado controla los sectores más
importantes desde el gas que vino de
rusia hasta la principal exportación del
país el potasio que por cierto se
utiliza para fabricar fertilizantes
habéis oído bien en muchos aspectos
bielorrusia seguí anclada en la unión
soviética y como os podéis imaginar
rusia es el principal socio comercial
del país con este panorama muchos
pensaréis que bielorrusia siempre ha
sido un títere del kremlin verdad sin
embargo nada más lejos de la realidad no
importa quién venga a las tierras
bielorrusas yo lo voy a combatir incluso
si es putin alexandr lukashenko habéis
oído bien lukashenka puede ser un aliado
de putin pero no es un títere de hecho
su política ha sido muy pragmática sí es
cierto la economía mantiene un sistema
medio comunista y muy conectado con
rusia pero también han recibido toda
clase de ayudas financieras de la unión
europea y no sólo eso al más puro estilo
del comunismo chino lukashenka también
ha creado zonas económicas especiales
[Música]
y aquí es donde entra el famoso hi tec
industrial parque creado en 2005 se
trata de un intento de crear un pequeño
silicon valley versión soviética las
empresas de este parque industrial están
exentas de pagar impuestos de sociedades
tampoco pagan impuestos de bienes
inmuebles y los trabajadores tienen un
tipo lineal de impuesto de la renta del
9%
[Música]
y diréis de verdad ha funcionado este
silicon valley soviético pues lo cierto
es que si para que os hagáis una idea en
el año 2018 el hi tec industrial parc ya
contaba con 368 empresas tecnológicas
que daban trabajo a 30.000 personas aquí
es donde nació por ejemplo el world of
tanks entre otros muchos videojuegos
puede parecernos un detalle sin
importancia pero recordad que hablamos
de un país de renta baja con 9 millones
de habitantes sólo este parque
industrial supone ya más del 1,5 por
ciento de todo el pib del país dicho de
otra forma que si podemos burlarnos de
lukashenko todo lo que queramos pero ha
conseguido lo que ni siquiera putin fue
capaz tener una industria tecnológica
competitiva a nivel internacional y de
hecho atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
si os fijáis veréis que bielorrusia es
casi el doble de rica que ucrania y esta
comparativa es especialmente dolorosa
ucrania puede ser un país corrupto sí
pero al menos intentó desarrollar una
democracia con todas sus imperfecciones
los ucranianos han podido disfrutar de
cierta libertad bielorrusia ni siquiera
se ha esforzado en mantener la más
mínima pose democrática es una dictadura
punto sin embargo en el campo económico
parece que el modelo bielorruso ha
funcionado mejor en otras palabras
lukashenka ha sido capaz de dar lo que
prometía estabilidad económica la
pregunta es hasta cuánto va a durar
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
vuelo de machos alfa
en el año 1990 bielorrusia se
independizó de la unión soviética en
1994 lukashenko se convirtió en el
dictador del país sin embargo en 1997 el
por entonces presidente ruso policial
sin firmó el tratado para el estado
unido con alexander lukashenko este
tratado era un intento para unir rusia y
bielorrusia en una entidad supraestatal
y como os podéis imaginar esto no es el
tipo de cosas que le hacen gracia a
ningún dictador a fin de cuentas todo
buen dictador quiere poder mandar sobre
su país sin ningún tipo de ataduras ni
dentro ni fuera de sus fronteras en el
momento en el que firmas un acuerdo con
un país mucho más grande que el tuyo ya
no puedes hacer lo que quieras
conclusión lukashenko le dijo a boris y
él si me mira por eso así que que sí que
bielorrusia rusia naciones hermanas
vamos juntos de la mano lo que tú
quieras yo te firmo lo lo que haga falta
yo te lo firmo pero luego lo de dar
pasos de verdad para un estado unitario
mira ya se hizo
los que tenemos es que tengo un lío
tengo un lío ahí en el gobierno y tal
pues mira ya si eso a lo mejor para el
año que viene y tal si quieres te lo
miro vale venga hoy a bolilla sin que
nos llamamos te llamo y esta ha sido la
postura de bielorrusia durante décadas
hasta que llegó este señor que veis el
partido
exacto vladimir putin y como ya sabéis
si a putin se le mete algo en la cabeza
no se le puede convencer de lo contrario
y por eso por el año más o menos 2019
putin le lleva lukashenko y le dijo
hombre alexander majete que pasa oye
mira que está haciendo así un poco de
orden en los papeles de la oficina del
kremlin encontró aquí este documento
estoy de acuerdo que tenía firmado con
rusia que esto que pasa el acuerdo es
que
con ellas
alexander lukashenko o lukashenko que no
sé ni cómo se pronuncia tu apellido
sabías muy bien lo que habías firmado
aquí y ya estás tardando en unirte a la
madre rusia como que me llamo vladimir y
así es como las relaciones entre
bielorrusia y rusia se empezaron a
torcer os lo contamos en un vídeo que os
dejo en la descripción putin lukashenka
se enzarzaron en todo un duelo de machos
alfa putin amenazó con cortar el
suministro de gas a bielorrusia y
lukashenko amenazó con robar el gas a
rusia literalmente incluso llegó a hacer
guiños al mismísimo eeuu parecía que
estos dos países estaban a punto de
convertirse en enemigos íntimos y
entonces ocurrió lo siguiente ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el pueblo unido ya ha sido vencido
en el año 2020 bielorrusia convocó
elecciones tranquilos tranquilos esto no
significa que se convirtieran en una
democracia las elecciones en bielorrusia
son tan falsas ni siquiera se esfuerzan
en ocultar que hacen trampas en este
caso lukashenko estaba listo para volver
a ganar las elecciones por nada menos
que un 80 por ciento del voto pero en
este caso la oposición estaba realmente
organizada así que las calles de minsk
se llenaron de manifestantes para que os
hagáis una idea la policía de lukashenko
llegó a meter en la cárcel a más de 6000
manifestantes y la lideresa de la
oposición svetlana hija no busca ya se
marchó al exilio en lituania desde ahí
se ha convertido en todo un símbolo
internacional y ya se lo qué pensaréis
muchos el pueblo unido jamás será
vencido' los viejos rusos se han unido y
los días del dictador están contados
[Música]
pues no siento defraudaros pero
lukashenka sigue en el poder porque
primero porque tiene el control del
ejército y la policía segundo porque la
economía iba moderadamente bien y
tercero porque en el último momento
aparecía su hermano mayor a rescatar
protestas de bielorrusia putin está
listo para enviar apoyo militar a
lukashenko conclusión las cosas han
seguido como siempre en bielorrusia la
unión europea dijo que estaba muy débil
y con sharp con bielorrusia y mientras
tanto world of tanks se convirtió en uno
de los videojuegos más populares de
rusia sin embargo el año 2022 lo ha
cambiado todo porque pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a juntar
[Música]
puede caer lukashenka
la pregunta del millón de dólares en
este momento es hay tropas bielorrusas
en ucrania ucrania dice que sí pero
bielorrusia dice que no que de ningún
modo que bajo ningún concepto el diría
en soldados a ucrania que os
preguntaréis pero porque quiero decir
lukashenka no es precisamente un
dictador con pelos en la lengua y putin
le ha pedido ayuda las tropas rusas
llevan casi un año estacionados en
territorio bielorruso además lukashenka
acaba de aprobar una constitución que
prácticamente pone a su país en manos de
rusia porque no manda su ejército o al
menos porque no se atreve a decir
abiertamente que lo hace pues atentos
apreciaciones y divisiones en el
ejército bielorruso previnieron que el
país se unirá a la invasión de ucrania
ojo puede que esta noticia no sea cierta
porque no deja de ser información que ha
dado la oposición bielorrusa pero lo
cierto es que todo apunta a que podría
ser verdad según varias fuentes incluso
el jefe del alto estado mayor habría
dimitido
pensado así una cosa es apoyar a un
dictador en tiempos de paz y dar algún
que otro por razón disidente otra muy
distinta es entrar en una guerra suicida
se puede ser malo pero no se puede ser
tonto aunque ahora que lo pienso
hay tropas bielorrusas en ucrania pues
en realidad la respuesta es que si
oficialmente podemos confirmar que en
ucrania hay tropas bielorrusas ahora
bien no son las que os esperáis créditos
de bielorruso se han unido a ucrania en
la lucha contra el imperialismo ruso
exacto la oposición bielorrusa está
mucho más motivada que el ejército
algunos se han ido a luchar ucrania y
otros se han quedado en el país haciendo
cosas como esto
bielorrusia resta cuatro personas por
intentar sabotear los ferrocarriles que
van para ucrania ojo porque esto ya no
son simples protestas estamos hablando
de una oposición muy motivada y bien
organizada pero no sólo eso con o sin
tropas en ucrania bielorrusia ha sufrido
casi las mismas sanciones económicas que
rusia y eso explica noticias como esta
la empresa más grande de videojuegos de
bielorrusia abandona el país y no son
los únicos prácticamente todo ese
silicon valley soviético del que
hablábamos antes está marchando y con él
todos los trabajadores hablamos de
empresas que están moviendo todas sus
plantillas a otros países y recordad que
bielorrusia no tiene ni gas natural ni
zumo de dinosaurio conclusión alexandr
lukashenko está en una situación mucho
peor incluso que vladimir putin no me
creéis pues mirad esta gráfica
[Música]
a diferencia del rublo ruso el rublo
bielorruso no se ha recuperado de la
devaluación es decir han sufrido los
efectos de las sanciones pero no han
sido capaces de hacer las maniobras
monetarias que ha hecho moscú pero no
sólo eso a diferencia de putin
lukashenko si tiene una oposición muy
bien articulada quien sería el mayor
opositor de putin probablemente alexéi
navalni que por mucho apoyo que tenga en
internet está en la cárcel en
bielorrusia la principal opositora de
lukashenko es sviatlana ti ya no busca
ya que ahora mismo está entrevistándose
con todos los líderes del mundo pero no
sólo eso a diferencia de putin
lukashenka no tiene el apoyo
incondicional del ejército es muy
difícil saber cuánta gente la apoya y
cuántos estarían incluso dispuestos a
levantarse contra él pero está claro que
ya no puede jugar con fuego así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros puede
caer alexander lukashenko de verdad
creéis que putin puede enviar muchas
tropas para protegerlo ahora que casi
todo su ejército está en ucrania es
posible hacer algo desde eeuu desde
europa para catalizar el fin de
lukashenko podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos las
semanas así que suscribió este canal y
darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
recordad también visitar nuestro nuevo
canal hermano visual economic donde
hablamos de nuestra otra gran pasión la
economía si os ha gustado este vídeo
donde al like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]